今日はパーリ語の百三十六ページです
まあこれからサーリプッタ
ガッダ・バーディプッタというお坊さんに対して話して
それからお釈迦様がこの我論ですね
実体がないんだという話に入っちゃうんですね
ですから このサーリプッタという人が別に我論を持っていたわけではないんですけどね
彼がこの欲ですね 性欲っていうのを別にもう修行に邪魔にならんだとという立場を取っていただけなんです
それにものすごくもう反対されちゃって
反対されただけじゃなくて
彼はもう相手にもしなくなっちゃったんですね
そのままもう捨てられちゃったというかね
あんた勝手にしなさいと言って
お釈迦様は比丘たちに話し始めるんですね
そこでお釈迦様がこの実体について
永遠不滅の魂っていうものがあるかないかっていうところについて語り始めちゃうんですね
そこでこの仏教を知っている人は
この全く実体というものはね
ないということは知ってるんだよという話に行っちゃうんですね
それの話し方はこのディッティッターナ
この我論 魂があるんだと我々は勘違いするところが六つありますと
この六つのところで我々は魂があるんだっていうところを勘違いするんだと
その六つなんですね 一番目は物体色ですね
体についていろんなくだらんことを考えちゃうと
妄想しちゃうと もう体の情報をはっきりわからないんだから
やっぱり魂があるんじゃないかなということになってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この感情で体を見ると
自分の肉体を見ると 魂があるんだっていうことになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこでこの体を訓練することで
体を整えることで心清らかになるんだろうという話もそこから出てくるんですよ
世の中の宗教っていうのは
大体そこら辺かなり激しく体いじるんですね
体を叩いたら魂も叩かれて
もうしっかりするんだと
体を焼いちゃうと もう魂もちゃんと煩悩が焼かれてもういいようになるんだぞと
そういうのを考えているんですね
それで体をそれなりにね
食べ物でコントロールしたり
いろんな運動をしたり
いろんな行をやったりして体を管理すると
それで魂が落ち着いて完成したことになるんだっていう話ですね
そうなっちゃうんですね
ですから 人々はこの本当は魂
魂って言っているのは
単なるこの肉体ではないかっていうね
それ一つのところで で
そこからこの肉体だから
お釈迦様は肉体は肉体だからね
ただ物質として見てみなさいよと
科学的に見ると 肉体っていうのは
まあただ壊れていくものでね
新しいものを入れて入れて新しく作りますからね
元のものはひとかけらもないしね
そういうふうにわかるでしょうと
二番目はジュウですね
この体の感覚 体の感覚について痛いと感じるは
楽しいと感じるはね 楽を感じるは
で 心でも まあそれ心のことをジュウは心なんですけど
で まあ楽しいや痛いや
それはまあ心で感じるものなんですけど
そういう感じるものについて
大変これが魂やと勘違いするんですね
ですから このそれで感じることもいつでも変わるんでしょうと
瞬間瞬間は変わっていくんだからね
それも魂とは取らない
ウェーダナーの次はサンニャンですね
サンニャンっていうのは
サンニャーっていうのは人間の思考というかね
概念ですね いろんなものを思って覚えて置いておくんですね
だから我々の学問 勉強
知ってることをたくさんありますね
それが私ではないかと思って錯覚するんですね
ですから この知識 概念
そういうのをサンニャーですからね
で そこで錯覚する人いますね
それが魂ではないかと
でも その知識 概念などももうみるみるうちに変わっちゃうし
みるみるうちに増えちゃう
だから増えたり変わったりするものだから
これはもう魂にならんですね
それからサンカーラっていうのはね
サンカーラっていうのはこの衝動というかね
心の中から出てくる この何かやりたいというね
喋りたい 歩きたい 食べたいとかね
勉強したいとかね もうなんとか行動を起こしてるんですね
生き物は この生き物は行動を起こす
その衝動なんですね サンカーラっていうのは
それ我々ははっきりわかってるんで
じっとしてはいられないんですね
何かしなくちゃっていうことはいつでもあるんですね
だから一瞬も我々は止まることなくいろんな行動をしているんですね
そのエネルギーがサンカーラではないかと言っても冗談なのに
それを随分変わっちゃうんですね
何かしようと思って 何か他の情報入っちゃうと
え やめましたと いきなりもう突然変わるんだから
だから衝動自体が決して当てになるものではないんです
だからサンカーラも我にならないんだと
それで 4つになりますね
次にこのディッタン スッタン ムッタン ヴィンニャータン パッタン パリエシタン アヌヴィッチャリタン マナサ
それから心の単なる知識のことをまたすぐに言うんですね
見たもの 聞いたもの 体で感じたものを頭で考えたもの
そういうものが魂だと勘違いするんだと
でもそういうものも変わるんだから
魂ではないんだよと それから
哲学的に宗教で教えていることがあるんですね
この生命 ソウロコウ ソワッタ
生命というのは魂だと
魂と生命は同一ものだと
変わらないんだと だから生命というのは魂だよという世の中にある考え方ね
それにしがみついて魂があるんだろうんだと思っている人もいるんだと
そういうふうなこの 6つの立場なんですね
大体我論というのはその 6つから出てくるんで
そこのところから出てくる枠はまるっきりない
だから世の中であるどんな魂に対する語っているものも
チェックしてみれば この 6つの中にいくつかに入っているんですよ
ですから 誰でも魂があるんだぞと思って信じているだけ
証拠あるわけじゃないんです
魂があるんだぞというこの錯覚を起こした原因を見てみたら
それが変化するんですね
ですから すごい単純に魂がないってことはわかるんです
今日はここからのそれは前の話の省略なんですね
エワン
グッテー アニャ タロー ビックー バガヴァンタン エー タド オーチャ シア アヌコー バンテー バヒッダ
アサテー パリタッサナーテー シア ビックーティー バガヴァー オーチャ
それでエワン グッテー
お釈迦様そうやって魂っていうのはないんだぞと言ったんです
2種類の魂がないんだったんで
自分のうち体の中にもないんだと
それから世の中と生命が同じだよというところの神学というか
外にも魂というものは全くないんだと
両方とも空やと内も外も
言ったらあるお坊さんが質問するんですね
お釈迦様は外にも何もないんだったら
カラだったら何か不安になるんじゃないかなと
パルタスナートナ すごい不安になってしまうんですね
ですから どういうことかというと
人間っていうのは外に頼っているんです
神様にお守りに 仏様に誰かに頼っているんですね
だから無知な人っていうのは
宗教があってもなくても
何か自分を支配して 支配されて管理されているんだよと思っているんですね
誰かに だからこれ 宗教と関係ない
これはどんな人間にもある問題なんです
誰かに自分のことを 管理されているんだと
それでみんなその大変優しく管理されているんだと思ってるんです
実際はそんなにそうかなと
世の中で成功して気楽にいる人っていうのはものすごい 1万人に一人ぐらいもいないだからね
そんなに優しく管理されているわけでもないんですけどね
それでも思ってるんですね
とにかく何かいいことがあるんだ
あるんだと どんな苦労して生きていたっても
やっぱり苦労すればするほど神に頼る傾向が強くなっちゃうんです
神様でもなかったら こんな苦労は乗り越えられないんだと
そういうふうにまで思っちゃうんですね
そういうことだから この全ての人々っていうのは
外に何か我々は守ってくれる何か魂
何か神 何か仏さんとか
何かがあるんだというふうに思っている
だからその傾向なんですね
いろんなこの迷信 この祈祷
そういうものも成り立っているのは
外にあるものから自分を守ってくれるんだという
それでお釈迦様 それはもうきれいさっぱり否定しちゃったんだから
空やと何もないんだと言ったら
そのお坊さんがもうそういう風になっちゃうと外に何もないんだとしたら
やっぱりかなり不安になるんではないかと
言ったら お釈迦様はそうですよと
不安になりますよと スヤービクゥーティバガワーオーチェ不安になりますよと釈尊が言うんです
そちらは少々ブラマン教ヒンドゥ教の考え方にお釈迦様が重点を置いてますけど
例えばキリスト教の方々も外に神様がいるんだと思って頼ってはいるんですけど
この外にいる神様とこちらにいる人間っていうのは同じものではないんですね
キリスト教では 神は絶対的で
全く人間は神にはなりませんと
神の機嫌を取っておけば
そこで天国には入れてくれる
それだけ天国とは別な枠なんですね
神が神とあの連中いるんですね
あの連中が別なグループで偉い立場にいるんですね
そこで神は死んでも聖器麻酔になっても人間に神は見えませんだそうです
そこで最後の審判で出てくるのはイエスなんですね
彼が王様として現れてきて
みんなを審判して みんなを首を切っちゃうんですね
大勢の人々の首を切らないと
だからキリスト教の方が少ないんだから
お互いに喧嘩しているキリスト教の諸宗派に対してどんな審判出すかわかりませんですけどね
カトリック教とプロテスタントいうのもものすごいお互いに対立しているんですけどね
そこは置いておいて だからキリスト教の神の場合は同じものじゃないんですね
いくら苦労しても別のもの
神と人間の魂が だから魂が神からくれたもので
それはもう永遠に幸福にしてあげるんだということになっている
だから 父と子と聖霊という三つになっているんですね
それでインドのブラマン教におけると
神と人間っていうのは同じなんですね
一つなんです だから絶対的な神がどこかにいるんです
隠れているんだけど その神そのもの
神っていうのは純粋に魂だけがだけなんですね
この純粋な我と自分の体に入っている我はまるっきり同じもの
同一ものやと思ってるんです
それでこちらで体を潰して
純粋な我だけ なんとかろうででも焼いてね
もう何とかして我だけ取り出してみれば
それがもう何のことなくぴったしと神と一体になっちゃうんですね
それは現代ヒンドゥー教
昔のブラマン教の基本的な教えなんですね
お釈迦様にとっては 言論としては一番派手に出てきたのはその人々だから
そちらの考え方については捨ててしちゃうんですね
ですから お釈迦様 次にこう答えるんですね
やっぱり外にないと これ不安になるんだよと言うと
不安になりますよと それから次の説明はそういう風になっちゃうんですね
イダビクゥーエカッチャッサーエワンホーティアフワタメタンワタメナッティスヤーワタメタンワタアハンネラバーミーティ
ある人にこうなるんだと
ある人にこういうふうな考え方をするんです
アフワタメ 確かに今まで私は外に絶対的な実体があったんではないかと
これが今更もうまるっきりないんだよと今言ってるんではないかと
これは証券に例えてみてください
自分たちがもういっぱい証券を持ってる
これ家にある限りは 俺はお金がありますよとすごくもう自信満々で生きてるんです
そこで証券買って持ってる人がなぜ自信満々でいるかというと
やっぱりその持っていたらそちらで大きな組織があって
そちらにはもう大量にお金があるんです
自分がそちらの証券買っているだけなんですね
ですから もう安心だよと
それで誰かの話聞く 話聞いて
あんたはなんとか証券持ってる
持ってますけど あの会社もうないんだよと
そんなものは最初から無効でしたよと
発行したその瞬間からもう
今まで例えば何千万円も自分にはあるんだと思ってた人は
どういう風になるんですかね
ものすごいショック受けるんです
バブルの時にゴルフ券とかね
会員権とか持ってて これが五千円でも売れるんだぞとか思っていて
後で百万円と いきなりもうショック受けちゃうんですね
ですから このアフワタメというのはそういう意味なんですね
私は自信が満々で生きてきたんだと
この手形持っていて で
これはお金に換金しようと思ったところでもないというと
この換金するどころかそういう場所もないんだと
そんなもの発行した時点でも
そんなものはただの紙だけでしたよとと言っちゃうと
だからこの証券の例よりもひどいんですよ
ショックは 証券なんかはね
まあ発行する時だけでも
もう人がいて 口約束ぐらいでもあるんだからね
で もっとひどいショックを受けちゃうんですね
タンワタメナッティ それが今私にはないんだよと
二番目はスヤーワタメタンワタハンノラバーミ
スヤーワタメというのは私に可能性がありましたと
いわゆる約束みたいなもんなんですね
可能性がありましたと
どんな可能性かというと
死んでから永遠不滅になる約束があったと
いわゆるこういう単純な日本語にすれば
私は死んでから永遠不滅になるはずでしたよと
スヤーというのはあり得るだろうということ
動詞なんです こうすればこうなるでしょうという条件付きの話の場合はスヤーと読むんですね
例えば 今の現代宗教はどんな宗教でもスヤーの立場なんです
一番の立場 誰も取ってないんです
アフワタメ例えば取ってないんです
確かに 私にはもう我があるんだっていう
これはもう確かに永遠不滅
何しても 人が死んだら確実に永遠不滅になるんだと
これはもうはっきりしているんだということ
立場が番目なんです そうすると
別に修行なんかする必要ないんです
人だったら死んだらもう永遠不滅のところに行く
その宗教っていうのはどこにもなかなか目立たない
2番目 シヤという可能性にはそこら辺あるんですね
例えばキリスト教だったら
必ずもう天国に永遠な永遠な天国に生まれ変わりますけど
それ欲しければもうイエス様を信仰して懺悔でしたっけをして
洗礼を受けておかないと
それで懺悔して洗礼を受けたらもう反抗してくれるんで
あんたもう天国やと ただそれだけ
それしなかったらもうダメなんです
それが幸せという状態なんです
条件付き そこで洗礼を受けている人がすごい自信満々で
俺はもう大丈夫やと もう死んじゃったらもう永遠な楽園で生まれ変わりますよと言ったところで
誰かがそんなアホなことはありえないんだよと言っちゃうと
ないんだと そんなものをと言っちゃうと
やっぱり天国に生まれ変わる可能性あったんだけど
もう今ないんだと もう大変心配するんですね
だからヒンドゥー教にしたっても同じことで
いろいろ行をやらないと天国には生まれ変われませんね
だからしあわてめという立場をとっているんですね
で 阿弥陀さんの教えにしたっても
南無阿弥陀仏と言って阿弥陀さんに任せないとそちらへ行かないんですね
そこの人のことを阿弥陀さんが何するかわからないんですね
その人々に聞きたいんだけどね
そこで また魂信じている宗教といえば天台かな
みんな魂ね 禅宗以外はね
みんな魂っていうのを信じてますけど
禅宗も魂を信じているいないとはあまりはっきり定かじゃないんですね
もう何もはっきりしないんだからね
禅宗は そこでもうみんなブッダだよと
生命は というと この その場合は番目なんですね
みんなに菩提心があって
仏心があって 如来蔵があって
もういろいろあるんですね
永遠な宝物 心は本来もう成仏しているんだと
そうすると別に修行なんかくだらんことしなくてもいいんです
ただもう好き勝手なことをして生きていて
死ねば それでもそれぐらい自信満々です
自信満々ですよ それをもうその
その教え考えている人は
この本覚寺の人々なんか
我々はもうゴミだと思っているんで
ある若者がなんか自分がすごいブッダっていう気持ちで私喋っていたんだからね
言うんです 私たちはその得度式を受けた途端
もう如来ということになるんだと
得度式ていて それだけで如来になって
いや まあ大変でしたけどね
今はそんなこと言われると我慢しません
もう年だからね 前は一応忍耐はありましたけどね
それ番目 このアホはてめ二番目しあわてめしあわてめっていうのは
もうそのこの子の行をやれば永遠の天国に行ける約束でしたでしょ？と
私はその行をやっていたんだから
ずいぶん安心していたんではないかと
タンワタハンナラバミ
それは得られないんだというんだよと
それは得られません こちら番目で言っているのは
こういうこのいろんな行をするならば
永遠不滅になりますよという諸宗教の話なんです
諸々の宗教の話 ユダヤ教でもいろいろ行やらなくちゃいけない
ユダヤ人でなきゃ天国に行けませんだけど
それだけでも足らないし
行もやらなくちゃいけない
ヒンドゥー教でも行やらなくちゃいけない
仏教にあるいろんな宗教も魂信じている大乗仏教にしても
やっぱりいろいろ行をやらないと
五幕養でもやらないと煩悩がなくならないんだっていう風にもやっているんですね
その二つですね 宗教で言えば一つはもう絶対的生命だったら
もう死んじゃったら天国に行くのは決まっているんだと
その場合は道徳 修行 倫理ってあまり関係なくなっちゃうんですね
もう約束しているんですね
例えば我々が誰が死んでも死体になるんだとということと同じなんです
我々人間だけではなくて
動物でも死んじゃったら死体になるんだよと言ったら当たり前でしょうね
我々別に死体になるための準備しなくちゃいけないんですかね
これから死体になる準備しておこうと
死体になるためにはこの食べ物を食べなくちゃあかんとかね
ありますかね 死体になりたければ
こういう食べ物はもう食べてはいけませんとか
こういう食べ物を食べなさいと
何もないんです とにかく死んじゃったら死体になります
それぐらいはっきりしている宗教と死んだら天国に行く
終わり 死体になるための準備いらんと同じく
それには準備も何も要りませんという宗教と
死んじゃったらこういう条件満たしているならば天国に行くという宗教ですね
その宗教の二つ だからこの皆様方もこのこうやってこの方程式をまず作ってから
世の中のことを見てください
お釈迦様のやり方はそういうやり方です
まず方程式を作って その方程式でもう全部理解してみる
そうするともうたくさんぐちゃぐちゃ勉強しなくても単純に分かります
世の中にあるユダヤ教であろうが
もう何教であろうが イスキリスト教であろうが
モルモン教であろうか
同じことを言ってるでしょう
何か行をやって 何かをしきたり踏んだら永遠という話でしょうに
一番目はあんまり本覚師匠の方以外はなかなか出てこないんですけど
本覚師匠を語っている人々もものすごい矛盾に出会って
これ修行しなかったら商売にならないんだからね
だから自分が言ったことで
自分の宗教そのものを壊れちゃうんですよ
なんでそんなバカでかいお金かかってね
お寺なんか作ってある必要あるんだよ
もうそれ潰せということになっちゃうぜ
ですから 本覚師匠は偉そうなことを言ったんだけど
言ったその瞬間でもう自分の土台が自分で壊しちゃったんですね
でもずっと一つの宗教組織としてもう生活しなくちゃいけない
だったらそれは商売だけのことなんですね
そこですごい矛盾に出会ってしまっちゃったんで
なんで修行する必要あるんでしょうかと
全然答えがない まあそれ以外
世の中でそういう宗教っていうのは唯物論以外はないんですね
唯物論は インドの唯物論は一つの宗教の色付きすごかったんです
この現代人の唯物論とは違いましたしね
ですから この唯物論はものすごい徹底してあったし
インドで インドの言葉でローカーヤタというんですね
ローカーヤタフィロソフィーという
マテリアリズムと英訳するんですね
ローカーヤタというのは
この世の中基準にして語っているんだというね
いわゆる見える範囲で見える基準で
それ以上は語らない だからこのある点でのお釈迦様にも似ている基準で
お釈迦様もこのこの見える知られる基準以外は語ってはいかんと
それはもうインチキになっちゃうんだと
妄想だけになっちゃうんだと
証拠ないんですね ですから
その論理構造っていうのはいろんなところで似ている
例えば なぜ魂が汚れているんだぞとというジャイナ教の教えとヒンドゥー教の教えになってくると
汚れについてはまた似ていることを言っちゃうんだよ
お釈迦様も 怒りやら欲やらね
嫉妬 憎しみなどなどでもう心が汚れているのだと
ヒンドゥー教でもそんなもんがね
もうとんでもないことだ
それで魂が汚れるんだというんです
だからお釈迦様は心が汚れるんだと
向こうは魂が汚れるんだと
そこでヒンドゥー教の人々が同じことをあんたも言ってるんではないかと言ったところで
お釈迦様に怒られるんですね
冗談じゃないんだと あんた方汚れ汚れてどれぐらいあります？知ってますかと
なぜ汚れるか知ってますかと
例えば煩悩 煩悩でなぜ煩悩か知ってますかと
それつい答えられないでしょう
単なる何とか何とか取って言ってるだけですよと
ある人にね まあ心に 心に汚れがなければね
それが悟りだと私は思ってるんだよ
だからお釈迦様同じことだと
だったら赤ちゃんには私がいるんだというぐらいでも実感がないんだよと
だったら赤ちゃんが悟ってるんだということですかと
というと答えられないんですね
だから悟った赤ちゃんが後で悟らない状態になるわけじゃないしね
だからそこら辺でもうあんた方は法則がわかってないって
そこで喧嘩しちゃいますけど
とにかく煩悩修行の場合は似ているところあります
論理構成になってくると
もう唯物論者みたいにしっかりと見えるものを聞こえるもので論理する
だからと言って唯物論者の立場を取らない
唯物論者はみんな地水火風でできているんだと
それから心感覚というものもあるんだと
感覚は物質に依存して出てくるものだから
物質壊れると感覚も壊れてしまうでしょうと
それで終わりと もう賢者も愚か者もみんなそれで終わりやと
というところで 修行は綺麗に否定する
修行する必要はないんだと
修行したんだからといって
特別なご褒美っていうのはないんだと
親を尊敬したんだとかね
宗教家を尊敬したんだとか
お布施したんだとか そんな行で特別にこの体に何か入ってくるということはないんですよといて綺麗にもう否定するんですね
みんな同じですよと それは唯物論ですね
それでそうそうちゃきらまきパリでわてうらったりんかんだきさんもうはんあぱじゃき
私は死んでから天国に行くはずでしたけども
もう行けないと言っちゃうかと
私はこの行をやってるんだから天国に行ける約束があったのに
もうないと言うんだよと言って
ものすごくもう混乱する
パリでわて泣く うらったりんかんだき
胸なでながらもう泣き崩れる
さんもうはんあぱじゃき
魂がないと言っちゃうと
ものすごいもうさんもうはんもう混乱
錯乱する ええワンコビッケバヒダアサティパリタッサナホーティ
そのように外にない場合はもう混乱するんだよと
悩む 動揺しますよと お釈迦様は認めるんです
もう説法事実ですけど
もう語ったところで かなりみんな混乱して
もう錯乱するんだよということをね
それで次の質問
スヤパナバンテバヒダアタシアパリタッサナッスヤビッコオティバガワオチェイダビッコーエカッチャッスナエワンホティヤフーワタメタンワタメナッティスヤワタメタ
ンワタアハンナラバミーティソーナソーチャティナキラマティナパディデワティナウラッタリンカンダティナサンモーハンアーパッジャティ
あのお坊さんがまた質問するんだよ
お釈迦様はこの外に何もないと言ったところで悩まない人もいますかと
悩まない場合もありますかと
何も錯乱しない場合もありますよと
それはあの風に考えない人がね
私は確実に天国に行くはずでしたよと
そんなことを思ってない人がね
あんまりくだらんことを考えない
ただ今の瞬間で生きているっていうことなんですね
そんな人にとっては別にだからだから何よということになります
という状態になっちゃうんですね
私はこういう業をやっていたんだから
天国に行くはずでしたよと
私は洗礼を受けたんだから
もう天国に生まれ変われるはずでしたよとか
そんな約束 将来の全然そんなこと気にしない人だったら
別にもう錯乱はしませんと
次の質問 これはこのバヒダ
外の魂に外にある永遠な魂
神についての話なんですね
それから次の質問は 自分の体に入っている魂についての質問になっちゃうんです
スヤアヌコバンテアッジャッタンアサティパリタッサナ
お釈迦様アッジャッタンアサティ
内にない場合は混乱しますかと
だから直訳は内がない場合は混乱しますかって
でもこれ全て厳密な専門用語で
そのこれだけでわかるわけじゃないんだ
だから質問する側もかなりの物事を理解のあって
それは質問しているし
そこで内というのは自分の精神のことを自分には大変なありがたい魂があるんだという考え方なんですね
自分がただのガラクタじゃないんだと
尊い生命だという考え方なんで
価値入れてるんで 自分に対しては
尊いやと それがもう世の中でどんな人間でも自分に対しては一番高い価値入れてるんですね
世の中で人間の感情から見れば
一番高価なものというのは自分なんですね
それ以上高価なものはないんですね
だから そういう私がすごく高価で大事だと
何よりも私が大事だと思っているんだから
その先帝でみんな宗教哲学を作っているんです
それの一つ 我論の始まりなんですね
でもなぜかというと 誰も気づいてないんですね
自分が自分だけのことを世界で絶対的価値あると思っていることにはもう気づいてないんです
みんな偽善で いえ 私は私の
私はもう私のことよりも子供のことを心配するんだと
世の中のことを心配するんだと
人のことを心配するんだとかね
そうやって徹底的に偽善を語ってるんですね
だからこのそんな人間はいません
どんな人間でもすごく醜いんです
もう他の人っていうのはもうゴミ扱いなんです
ゴミやらゴキブリみたいな感じで
もう他の生命のことを考えてるんです
慈しみなんかはひと欠けらもないんです
私こそ絶対的で偉いと思ってるんです
それでなんで他人に優しくするかというと
自分の利益のためなんです
子供の面倒を見ると 自分がすごいもう楽しくてたまらないんですね
だから子供のためにもう死に狂いで苦労するのは
自分にとってはすごい充実感が得られるんです
だからやってるんです
だからこれは科学的でしょうね
これ DNA に書かれてるんだから
遺伝に この哺乳類動物は子供育てなくちゃいけないように遺伝に書かれてるんだから
やってるだけで ヒヨコがニワトリお母さん初めて見たものを母親と思っちゃうでしょうね
卵から出てくるヒヨコはもうもうどんな種類のヒヨコであろうか
初めて目に入った動くものが母親ですよ
それでいくんです キーキーキーと鳴きながら
おもちゃでもいいんです
卵から出てくると そこら辺におもちゃを動かすということで
おもちゃがもう母親なんで
自分より小さくたっても母親なんです
あれ後ろから行くんだから
ただそれだけ これは何のためかというと
やっぱり母親が行って餌をあるところを見つかりますから
それで後ろからいて そこで食べちゃうんですね
それで自分が生き続けますから
ただそれだけの指導あればいいんです
餌場はこれだよと だから放し飼いの鶏なんか見てください
この小さなヒヨコたちから
みんなもうキーキーと言いながら後ろからずっと行くんですね
それで母親がなんとか餌あるところをなんとか綺麗にしてしまうと
みんなそこに入り込んじゃって
全部パクパク食べちゃうんです
それで母鳥が他のところで
またもう足で全部引っ張っちゃうというかね
けずるんですよ けずっちゃうと
下の虫やらいろんなもの出てくるんですね
食べられる葉っぱとかね
またそちらに走ってきて
それだけで別にお熱が出ているかどうかね
そんなこと見る必要ないんですね
鶏の場合は だからそれぐらいの親子関係
哺乳類動物の場合はそれだけでは済みません
もっと手が焼いちゃうんですね
猿の赤ちゃんにしても
もうやっぱりまずおっぱいあげなくちゃいけない
それからもうすぐもう硬いものを食べられるわけじゃない
ゆっくりと食べさせてあげなくちゃいけない
それでも体が弱い それからまたそれぞれいろいろ面倒見なくちゃいけないと
だから猿はもう一人前になるまで猿の母親は抱っこしている
でもゾウやら馬やらね
抱っこすることはしません
だからその愛情っていうのは
この生命を維持するために必要な量しか入ってないんです
それは宗教的な素晴らしいということでもないんです
人間の場合は一番手がかかるんですね
人間の子供っていうのは
地球の生命の中で一番手がかかるのは人間の赤ちゃんたちなんです
ですから もう他の動物よりは自分の我が子に対する愛情っていうのは大きくなっているんです
そんなものはDNAで書かれているもの以外はやりません
誰も だからただ自分が刺激を受けちゃう
子供の面倒を見ると それ不思議なこと
見ただけでもものすごい楽しくなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうになっているだけ
だからそれが別に何か立派な行為というのも評価できないんです
ただ自然のことで ですから
そこで人間がそこで錯覚を起こして
家族知りませんから 錯覚を起こして
自分たちが優しいやと
大変親切やと 自分のことよりも人のことを心配するんだと
それが偽善錯覚なんですね
だから慈しみっていうのはわざわざそうせずなくちゃいかんことで
これは DNA にないものなんです
あれを勘違いしたら困るんです
慈しみというのは DNA に書いているものじゃないんです
だからもうなんとなくやろうとすると拒絶反応が起こるんですね
だから私の経験では 拒絶反応を起こした人々が慈悲が分かったんです
このテーラワーダのグループの中でも
全くすんなりとよく分かったという人々は
いまだに私は認めません
慈悲あるんだと で 私に対しても
そんなこと言ったってどうかなとか
なんとかとか 拒絶反応を起こした人々には素直に言ってあげちゃうと
そうですか それで二度と質問したこともなかったし
結構もう頑張っているっていうことを見るんですね
これ大変苦労しないと
もう心に育てられるものではないと知っていて
本能でも何でもないんだと知ってるんだからね
慈悲の話を聞いて なんと素晴らしい
私はもうやっぱりそういう話を探していたんだと言っちゃったら
もうこちらありがとうございますと
でも何年経ってもわからないんだと
あなたには だって違いますよと言えないでしょうに
怒ることもできないでしょうに
慈悲を説明すると ものすごく向かってくるんだよと言った人が正直で
その人には教えられますけどね
だからそういう精神は逆に憎しんだらいいと思いますかね
相手をと その瞬間で なるほど憎しんじゃうとダメやねとすぐわかっちゃうんですね
そこでこの自分というもの
絶対的な価値があると思う
他の生命としてはもう全くもうゴキブリレベルの扱いで
役に立つんだったら親切にしてあげるんだと
役に立たないんだったらもう潰しちゃうんだと
だから子供でも邪魔だったら殺すんだからね
それがもう精神的な異常なんですけど
日本でよく見られますけどね
自分の子供を殺すと これがちょっともう DNA でもそんなこと殺せないようにもう記録されているのに
敵を殺す大人を殺すことはできますけど
子供は殺せないはずなんですよ
人の子供でも それで自分の子を殺すっていうことは
もうもうすっごいもう精神錯乱っていうのはもう並みじゃないんです
で まあそれはそれで それでも論理わかるでしょ
自分の役に立たないと
まあもうゴミ扱いでしょ
結局は だからまあそこはもう偽善にならないように理解した方がいいんです
慈しみっていうのは これ別なもので
ないもので育てていくんですね
心に そういうことだから
みんな宗教を作る時でも本人も気がついてないんだけど
自分がすごい最高に偉いということを証明するために宗教作る
哲学を作る だから世の中の宗教
諸宗教 諸々の哲学 思想を見てください
結局はその立場なんです
宗教はなんで戦争するんですかね？なんで宗教語る人は人を殺すんですかね
ありえないでしょうに
論理的に考えちゃうと
でも宗教語る人まで人を殺しちゃうでしょうに
だから宗教であろうが政治家であろうが
政治家は当たり前のことなんですけども
みんな自分こそ絶対的な価値があるものや立場で語ってますよ
それは束はない それは言わない
言わないのは嘘じゃないんです
本人も分かってない 気づいてない
だから言わないだけ 他人のために
例えばトルコにローマ法王行ったでしょうに
それで あれ 平和のために行くんですかね
公で言うのはすごい立派な法王や平和
平和やとかね 何の平和のためでもない
トルコはイスラム教の国で
キリスト教の人々はかなり潰されているんですね
それで逆にトルコの正統
正統教というんですか
キリスト教の正統派というんですか
あれが 正教ですね で それとローマ教会とはものすごく腹が立ってるんですね
昔から そこら辺に行って
自分のカトリックをなんとかなんとかまた生き返ってもらおうという狙いというのははっきりしているんです
それでローマ法王のような人がね
行きたい行きたいと言っちゃうと断れないね
彼が政治家だから 政治家より力を持ってるでしょうね
アメリカ大統領よりも力を持ってるでしょうに
だから政治をやらない政治家だから
もうかなり力持ってます
政治をやる政治家にはそんな力がないんです
だから断れないし それで言ってイスラエルにも行くし
トルコにも行くし どこにでも行く
どこへ行っても平和語ってるわけじゃないんですよ
平和語りたければ まず自分の宗教を置いておいて語らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
簡単なことでしょう 宗教より以前
我々は人間だよと 宗教は後から付いたものだよ
それ一言言わんでしょうに
生まれてからでしょうに
宗教っていうのは イスラムであろうが
カトリック教であろうが
何であろうとも 生まれてからいつでも変えることもできるでしょうに
だからまず人間だから宗教をやるんであって
宗教があるんだから人間になったわけじゃないでしょうに
はっきりしたその論理がなぜ語らないかと
それさえもわからないんです
まず宗教がありき それから人間がありきっていう
宗教のために人間がいるんだという立場です
だから宗教のためにならなかったら殺してもいいということになっちゃうんです
だから宗教の世界でも人殺しやっているんです
そういう人殺しする宗教ですよと
自分が偉いんだから 自分がこういう宗教を信仰している自分が偉いんだと
だからその宗教を否定する人々には生きる権利がないんだよということになって殺したりする
だから政治家であろうと哲学者であろうが
いくら平和家であってもそう
人間論というのはわかっていない限りはね
人間は人間であるということがわかっていない限りはね
平和ということにはならないんですね
とにかくそうやって このものすごい誤解
ものすごい醜い この基本的な我々のすべての思考の土台っていうのは
我こそ絶対的だという
そのすごい醜い思考の土台で
すべての美しい世界を作っているんです
だからすごい矛盾だらけで
故に世の中では我論が成り立っているんです
私がいるんだと 魂があるんだと
死んでも死なないんだと
永遠になるんだという
その全ての言葉っていうのは
自分を評価するだけのこと
私に魂があるんだということは
この生ゴミの塊についてすごい価値入れているだけ
それで執着が生まれてくる
執着と同時に喧嘩やら戦争やら
もうありとあらゆる苦しみが出てくる
それでもう喧嘩しながら憎しみ合いながら
もうただ生きている それで死んじゃう
何やってるかと 何の安らぎも瞬間でも得られないんだ
だから執着を捨てなさいと
捨てた瞬間で全ての安らぎはそちらにあるんだと
怒りも憎しみも全部消えちゃうんだと
というのは お釈迦様のすごい合理的な教えなんですね
執着を捨てるという心の感情の転換だから
それはちょっと頑張ってもらわないと
ちょっと智慧が出てこないと
その感情が消えてくれないんですね
そこでうちがない うちがない
その意味なんですよ だからこれ単純じゃないんです
大変な教えなんです うちがないということは
我がないということなんです
そこでお釈迦様は次にそれを説明します
うちがないということになっちゃうと
みんなかなり錯乱しますよと
ある人がこう思いますよと
ソウローコーソウアッタ
ローコー 生命 アッタ 自分の自我
同じものやと 生命といっても自我といっても同じものやと
ソウペッチャバヴィッサーミ
そう その私がペッチャ
死んでから バヴィッサーミというのは動詞で
ニッチョウドウ 永遠になるんだと
常住になるんだと 死んでから
サッサトウ それはすべて専門用語
永遠常住という意味の
アヴィパリーナムダンム
全く変化しない 全くも変化しない
変わらないものになるんだと
私といっても世界といっても生命といっても同じものであって
私が死んだら必ずしも永遠になるんだ
永久的になるんだ 常住になるんだ
変わらないものに私がなるんだよと
そう思っている サッサティサマンタテーワタッサミ
これ インドにある宗教哲学を使っている言葉は全部こちらにまとめているんです
ですから それはまあ いわゆる永遠不滅になるんだっていう意味です
ソウスナーティタタハガタッサワタタハガタサワカッサワ
彼がスナーティ 聞く タタハガタッサ
如来の話 あるいは如来の弟子たちの話を聞く
その弟子たちの話は何ですかというと
サッベーサンディッティッターナパリュッターナアヴィニヴェーサナヌセーヤナンサムッガーターヤ
お釈迦様と弟子たちが何をしゃべるかというと
サッベーサンディッティッターナ
この邪見が生まれるこの土台
すべての土台 それからパリュッターナ
何に基づいてこの邪見が
邪見というのは我見ですね
私が偉いというこの邪見が生まれるかという
アヴィニヴェーサ 人間というのはそうやって何に執着しているかと
そのもの だから結局自分が偉い
自分が偉いと自分に執着しているんですね
自分中心に考えているんですね
自分を評価しているんですね
だから我論は六つの立場から生まれてくる
体を見て我論が出てくる
感覚から我論が出てくる
知識から我論が出てくる
また感情から我論が出てくる
また衝動から我論が出てくる
また勉強 見たり聞いたりすることから我論が出てくるという
その五つとまた六つですね
それから そうやって自分を評価して
私はこの価値論で言ったのは
この全てまとめて価値論にしちゃったんです
昔に 全部この自分には価値があるんだという
ただそれだけのことで
それはすべてサムッガータヤ
粉々に壊す説法を聞く
もう何の一欠片もなくサムッガータヤも壊す
それでサッバサンカーラサマタヤ
人間があれやりたい これやりたい
ああしたい こうしたいとかね
あるでしょうに 天国に行きたい
生まれ変わりたい 永遠になりたい
極楽堂 このサンカーラ全部もうないことにする
いわゆるこの衝動はもう冷めちゃう
やる気が粉々にしてもう壊しちゃう
だからサンカーラはサマタ
サンカーラっていうのはエネルギーだから
それは全部もうゼロにしてしまう
生きていきたいという
とにかく生きたいという
あれをもうエネルギーをゼロにしちゃう
サッブーパティパティニサッガーヤ
人間がいろんなもの あれ欲しい
これ欲しい あれがありがたい
これがありがたいと価値入れてるでしょうに
ウブディっていうのはいろんなものに価値
これは金はいい 銀はいい
宝石はいいとかね この建物はいい
この地表はいいとかね
家族は素晴らしいとかね
そうやって我々はいろんなものに価値入れてそれ囚われています
それだけじゃなく 自分にもものすごい巨大な価値を入れちゃって
究極的な価値を自分に入れちゃって
自分に執着しているんです
そのすべての執着を捨てるようにしちゃう
ゴミだと言っちゃうと捨てるしかないんだからね
ただのゴミと そんなものは自分で取っちゃうと苦しみしか出てこないんだと
言うとやっぱり執着捨てるしかなくなっちゃう
タンハッカヤエ 渇愛をなくすということ
ヴィラーガヤエ 無執着のために説法する
ニローダヤエ 滅つのために
燃やすためではなくて
全て滅することのために説法
ニッバーナヤエ 涅槃のために説法する
ダンマンデーセンタン
仏教の話はそんな話なんです
私にはかなり悪口批判言われちゃったんだけど
私はブッダの話をずっと語っていたつもりなんです
いろんなものを壊して潰して
もう全く文化も価値も何一つも気にしないで
この狂暴に喋っているのではないかと
口うるさいなと言っても
私はただブッダの話を語っているだけでしたけどね
この行でわかると思います
私はこの経典 あまりみんなに言わなかったんですけど
これは難しいんですからね
でも内容はちゃんと伝わったつもりなんです
一欠片も歪曲させないで
そのまま純粋に そのようなブッダの話聞くと
私こそ絶対的な価値があるんだよと思っていた人が
ブッダの話聞くと もう錯乱します
ウッチッディッサミナマス
なんだ全部消えちゃうかと
全部虚無になるんでしょうかと
ウィナシッサミ 全て 破壊するんだと
私が破壊になるんだ 私が虚無になるんだ
私が消えるんだって これえらい錯乱するでしょうに
自分が究極的な価値があると思った人は全くないんだと言っちゃうと
これすごい錯乱します
ネスナーマバギッサと言って
私はもうこれからいないんだと言ってるんだよと
そう承知でキリマティパリレレは胸を叩きながら泣くんだと
それで逆の話もありますね
誰かが家に蛾がないと聞いたところで悩まない人いますかと
いますよと それが私は永遠になるんだぞとかね
そんなくだらんことを考えていない人が
お釈迦様の話を聞いても
別に錯乱はしませんと
そこでお釈迦様は次に無我論に入るのです
これは仏典にある無我論なんですね
仏典という経典にあるね
経典の言い方を私は変えましたけどね
現代風に でも根拠はこちらなんですね
テキストの お釈迦様はすごい正直に語る
タン
ビッキャウェーパリッガハンパリッガンヘイヤーテワッサパリッガウニッチョドゥオーサッサトーアウィパリナーマダンモーサッサティサマンタテーワティッテッイヤ
お釈迦様が言うのは 永遠なもの
絶対的なもの 全く変わらないもの
常住もの 堅固なものが捕らえてもいいんだよと
捕らえなさいよと言っているのです
もしあるならばの話なんですけど
永遠なもの 常住もの 堅固なもの
決して変わらない普遍的なもの
変化しないものが ものを捉えなさいよと
だって変わらないものだから
それに執着しても悪くないんだよと
いわゆる普通の話言ってるんです
それ言って そんなものを捉えなさいよと
永遠なもの 常住なもの
堅固なもの 捉えなさいよと
まず言って 次にそんなものありますかと
あなた方には見いだせますかと
次に質問するのです 絶対的なものをあなた方には発見できますかと
パッサテ 見えますかと Can
you see? Can you discover?だから見いだせますかと
あなた方に 永遠なもの
常住なもの 堅固なもの
絶対変わらないものが何か見いだせますかと
あなた方には 見いだせるんだったら取ってくださいと
いわゆる単純な論理 魂があるんだったら魂に執着しなさいよと
あると見いだせますかと
だから論理にお釈迦様は反対じゃないんです
死すべき人間が死なない不死なるものに憧れると
これはもう分かります
気持ちは もし不死なる状態があるんだったら
魂が不死なるものだったら
その魂に執着して魂だけ浄化したってもいいんです
それは悪くないんです
あるならばなんですね
だからまずやる必要は
そういう魂があるかないかと探すことなんです
誰もやってないのはそれなんです
魂があるんだぞとすぐ決めつけている
あれはものすごい誤解なんです
あれは自分を過剰評価したことの結果なんです
あれが自分こそ絶対的な価値があるんだと
自分のこの肉体に対して
肉体から出てきた単なる感情なんですね
科学的な発見ではないんです
そういうふうなことを論理的に言っているんです
そんなものありますか？見いだせますかと
魂のようなものと言ったら
比丘たちがノーヘタンバンテ
ないんだと 見いだせませんと
サードゥビッキャウェ
よし よかったと サードゥ
それはいいと アハンピコービッキャウェタンパリッガハンナサムヌパッサーミ
イワッサパリッガウニッチョドゥーオサッサトーアリパリナーマダンモーサッセタテワティッテイ
お釈迦様は そうですよ
私もそういう永遠不滅の絶対変わらない
何か実体を見つけてないんだと
私も見つけてないんだと
だからお釈迦様もじっと探検して探検して
ないと 我がないということに来て
私も見つかりませんよと
あなた方はそんなことを探検すると見つかりますかと
見つからないんだと それで次の立場
タン
ビッキャウェアッタワーダウパーダーナンウパーディーエタヤンッサアッタワーダウパーダーナンウパーディーエトナウッパッジャイユンソーカパリデーワドッカドゥーマナッスーパヤーサ
アッタワーダっていうのは我論という意味なんですね
我について語っている説法
宗教 我について語って
その考え方を受け取って信じて
苦しみにならない 幸せになる
そういう 教えがありますかと
いわゆる何かに囚われてください
何かを取ってくださいと言ったところで
人間には苦しみ 悩み 悲しみが出てこない
そういう教えがありますかと
もっとややこしい もっと簡単にしなくちゃ
もっと簡単にします 私はこの教えを信仰することで
大変気楽で楽しく生きてるんだよと
私にはもうこの宗教を教えと信じていることで
何の苦しみもないんだよというふうな戯論がありますかと
だから戯論自体が価値入れることなんです
人間には魂があるんだと
霊があるんだと 霊魂が
言っただけで 結局苦しみ悩みが生まれてくるんです
生きることはさらに大変になっちゃうんです
楽に生きていられなくなるんだから
聖書なんか読んでみてください
まず怖くなるんですよ
だってはっきり書いてるんだから
神が人間を作って魂を吹き込んで
それからその魂が汚れて
それで神を信頼することによって
信仰することによって
神からこの魂を浄化させてもらわないと
永遠な地獄で火に焼かれるんだと
そんなことを信じちゃうと
みんな怯えて生活しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
その教えに言われる通りにやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから何かに価値入れると
そこから苦しみが生まれてくるんです
例えば 人間っていうのは自分以外番目に価値いるのは自分の子供たちでしょうに
一番価値あるのは自分
次に番目に価値あるのは自分の子供たちなんですね
それで じゃあ自分の子供たちから苦しみが出てこないんですか？悩みが出てこないんですかね
自分の子供に何か起きたらどうですかね
心は だから価値 子供には価値入れる
子供に価値入れちゃうと
もうもうずっと死ぬまで親が悲しむんですよ
親が心配するんですね
子供のことを どうにもならん
子供が病気になったら痛いの親なんですね
本人よりも 子供が試験が落第しちゃったら
ものすごい悲しむのは本人じゃないんです
本人はあっけらかんとしているんだけど
親なんですね ですから
物に価値入れると 必ずしもそちらには並ならぬ苦しみ
悩みっていうのはもう付いているんです
お金やら宝石やら いろんなものをいっぱい持ってると
持てば持つほどもう死ねなくなっちゃうんです
いっぱい財産があると
それで子供たちが喧嘩しちゃう
親戚が喧嘩することになっちゃう
人が死ぬ前にもう殺されちゃうんですね
もう早く遺言書を書きなさいよとかね
残酷でしょうね  1 日でも長生きして
貧しい人々だったらね
別に残す財産ない人だったら
自分の親やらね  1 日でも生き延びてほしいとかね
一生懸命なんですけど
豊かな家族だったら全然その愛情も何もない
兄弟の間でお互いに憎しみ合っちゃうんですね
遺言書であなたにはもう50パーセントあげてるでしょうと
これはおかしいやと 親の面倒見たのは私ではないかと
色々色々でしょうに ですから
この何かに それからが出てくるのはものすごい苦しみなんです
だからこちらで言っているのは
この師匠 教え 宗教 哲学についてあったわけで
何か我論がありますかと
それに執着しちゃうと苦しみ
悩みがないという我論が
だからお釈迦様から見れば
我論を信仰すると単純に苦しみ悩み生まれてくるだけなんですね
だから余計なことを信じる必要ないんだよと
単純な例で言えば 我々は食べ物について余計な学問的な知識を得ているでしょうに
食べ物については 本当は学問的な知識っていうのはよくないんです
食べ物っていうのは本能で知ってるはずなんです
何が食べられるか 何が食べられないかっていうこと
犬には学校はないし ライオンにも学校はないしね
食べるべきものと食べてはいけないものと
でもちゃんと知ってるでしょうに
栄養失調になっている動物はいません
いますけど それは獲物取れなかったんだから
コレステロールが高いという動物は 1匹もいません
人間飼っている動物以外は
高血圧の動物は 1匹もいません
人間飼っているとまた違いますけど
ですから それは DNA に書かれてるんですよ
何が食べるべきか 何が食べてはいけないか
それで我々は食べ物を分析して
成分を分析して こちらのはこれがある
こちらのはこれがある
こちらのはこれがあるとかね
1 日アイアン鉄分がこれぐらい取らなくちゃいけない
C はこれぐらい取らなくちゃいけない
そう言っちゃうと もうだいたい半トンぐらい 1 日食べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それで威張って読んで見せるんです
1 日の食物繊維はこれぐらい取らなくちゃいけないんだと
250MG 取らなくちゃいけないんだと
250MG の繊維を取るためには
キャベツはどれぐらい食べなくちゃいけないかと
ものすごいキャベツは 10個ぐらい
キャベツ 10個 1 日食べられますかとかね
そんな感じでまた威張ることはこれぐらい量を取らなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そう言って 結局それ聞いてる我々はすごい心配する
まあそこら辺に何か手当たり次第食べて生きていれればいいのに
あの楽な生き方っていうのはそれで消えちゃうんです
それで皆さんやっぱりこれぐらいキャベツ食べないんだけど
このカプセルは 2つ飲めばいいんだよと
1 日 3つ  4つ飲めばいいんだよと
で  1箱は 1万5000円で
もうなんで安いんですかとまた言うんですね
それで買ったりすると
だからそんなことによって
我々は余計な知識が入ることによって幸せになるんではなくて
まるっきり逆になるんです
だから体に悪い もう化学物質はバンバン入れちゃう
それにお金もかかる それで一つ売れると思ったら
各会社でほとんど同じものを作っちゃう
それで競争する だから余計な知識さえも
私たちにとっては楽に生きるということを邪魔しているだけなんです
だから 宗教にしたっても
哲学にしたっても同じことなんです
そんなものあります？って言ったら
比丘たちが いえ そんな何か師匠
何か哲学 何か宗教を信仰したら
もう苦しみが出てくるだけですよと比丘たちは認める
お釈迦様もそうですよと
その通りですと 私も知りませんと
そんな教えは 信仰したことで幸せになるとはならないんだと
結局苦しみが増えるだけですよと
次にディッティニッサーヤンということ
ディッティニッサーヤンというのは
何か主義を持つこと 見ですね
邪見ですね 魂は小さいや
魂は大きいや 魂は永遠だとか
いろいろ意見 邪見 いろいろあるんですね
唯物論も一つのディッティなんですね
偏見ですね 何か主義を持って生きてると楽やと思ってますかと
結局どんな主義でも持っちゃうと楽にならないので
自分の主義を守らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
主義を弁解しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
その主義に反対した人々と喧嘩しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
私は菜食主義やと思った途端
すごい苦しくなっちゃうんです
それだけでも 菜食主義に反対する人々もいますからね
それにも戦わなくちゃいけないし
それで肉魚食べるところに行ったらもう困らなくちゃいけないし
たとえ菜食主義やと思っただけでも
まあ楽になるどころか
いろいろ苦しみが出てくる
他の主義でも同じなんです
だから何か主義を持って楽になる
気楽になるということはありません
ないんだよと比丘たちも言うし
お釈迦様はそれを認める
次にまた時間ないんですけど
この次の論点だけ言います
この我があるならば もし実体として我というものをね
永遠の魂というものがもしあるならばです
あるならば人間に我があるんだよと
私には我と関係あるんだよと
そういうふうに思えるでしょうと
その通りですよと 比丘たち答えるんですね
もしその論理で世の中でその論理があるんで
だからみんな神様がいると思っているんだから神様がいるんでしょうと
みんなただそういうだけで
お釈迦様はもっと厳密に言うんです
もし神様がいるんだったら
みんな神様がいると思うでしょうと
だから我があるならば
やはり我があるんだよと
私は我に関係あるんだよと
私にも我があるんだよというふうに思えることは正しいでしょう
正しいです もし我がないならば
もともと無我だよ無我だよと思えることは正しいと思います
それも正しいんです その論理の 2つの思考に基づいて
次のところは広げていくんです
お釈迦様は証拠を出すんです
無常という証拠 出しちゃうと我がないということははっきりするんです
もし一つでも無常だと証明できれば
もう我がないことは確かなんです
だから我があるんだったら
いくらもうもう潰してみても我が見いだせる
あるんだからしょうがないんですね
その論理なんですけど
まずまあまあ我があるならば我を発見できるでしょうと
みんな我論に陥るのは問題ないでしょう
問題ないんです 我があるんだったらね
もし我がないんだったら
無我論に入るのはどうでしょうか
それは問題ないんです
それでお釈迦様がものは無常やと説明するんです
故に我がないということになっちゃうんです
証拠は無常だったらもう無我ですよと
だからお釈迦様はすごい厳密に説明するのは
この証拠をすべて無常を証明しているのに
すべては無常だから我がありますよという
このいい加減な屁理屈には反対しているんです
すべての証拠は無常だったら
なんで故に我と言うんでしょうかね
あなたに対しては何の証拠もないんだから
あなたは犯罪有罪ですということと同じでしょうに
裁判で 裁判で訴えられたところで
検視の方は警察の方はもういろいろ証拠を出そうとする
そこでこの犯罪が起きた時は
その人は外国にいたとかね
きちんとしたアリバイもある
確かに外国にいた写真までもある
パスポートの判子までもある
出国入国の そこまであるんだから
それで裁判官はね あなたに対してはひとかけらの証拠はない
故にあなたが有罪ですと
という 決めちゃうと もうバカのいいところでしょうに
世の中っていうのはすべて無常ということには証拠はあるんだけど
我を 我の結論を出すんです
インドの哲学者であったラーダ・クリシュナンという大統領も
お釈迦様は無我と言ってないんだよと
無常たるものは我やと勘違いすることに反対しただけですよと
お釈迦様はヒンドゥー教
ヒンドゥー教だと 絶対的な我を認めているんだと
という結論なんです 学者のくせに
だから不屈がおかしいっていうことは
偉大なるどんな ものすごい学者です
ラーダ・クリシュナンという大統領が
何の役にも立たないんです
仏教のはいかに智慧ですかというと
これはどこかというと
自分を高く評価するところで
その欠点に陥っちゃうんです
では  他の日にしましょう
今日は終わるだろうと思ってたんですけど
やっぱり難しいですね
ありがとうございました